alors je pense que je pense qu'il
fallait la direction du parti a fait un
choix est respectable mais qui n'est pas
le mien qui est qui et qui est celui de
en fait de coller au discours de marine
le pen est pas forcément ça plaît aux
gens aux électeurs de marine le pen mais
ils votent pas pour autant que pour la
droite il vote pour l'extrême droite les
gens les électeurs le pen forcément
c'est normal et cette manière maintenant
je vous ce qui moi me terrifie
d'ailleurs parce que c'est tellement pas
ma conception de notre parti gaulliste
mais beaucoup maintenant de vos
confrères disent la ligne wauquiez le
pen le pen wauquiez 1 et c'est terrible
parce que ça ne représente qu'une petite
partie
l'électorat de droite quoi mais ces deux
réalités pour une ligne wauquiez le pen
laurent wauquiez dit je ne peux tu ne
veux pas m'interdire de parler
d'immigration et de sécurité au boss a
heureusement oui mais c'est vrai alors
c'est par exemple on n'a jamais dit
pourtant dû sait si j'ai défendu la
droite décomplexée j'ai jamais entendu
dire la ligne copé le pen enfin je
n'étais pas l'ambiance moi j'ai toujours
été extrêmement ferme par rapport à
cette question et vous avez subi les en
votre temps le même procès a donc c'est
vrai monsieur non enfin s'agit sud pour
celui des attaques mais mais comme tout
le monde mais ça non parce que justement
on a été toujours extrêmement claire par
rapport à cette question
mais au-delà de ça je pense que oui par
exemple sur l'europe
moi j'ai toujours été extrêmement clairs
sur la question européenne et je me suis
reposé l'époque parce que laurent
wauquiez voulait créer un lien qui lui
proposait une europe à 5
maginez donc qui était la ligne de le
pen d'ailleurs un voilà typiquement un
sujet sur lequel il ya malheureusement à
droite une un vrai débat pour ne pas
dire une fissure quand même donc c'est
des sujets complets